find the probability of rolling doubles
on two six-sided dice so these are just
the regular types of dice that you're
used to playing with on with monopoly or
any kind of typical board game numbered
from 1 to 6 so rolling doubles doubles
would be getting maybe two ones or maybe
getting two threes getting the same
number showing up on the top of both of
the dice so that's what we would need to
figure out the probability of so to do
that let's think about all of the
possible outcomes so let's think about
the sample space right over here so
let's say we have the first to die first
die I'll do in this column so here the
outcomes for the first die you can have
a 1 the 2 a 3 a 4 a 5 or a 6 and then
let's say for the second die so a second
to die I'll do in this right over here
I'll have the columns label to the roll
on the second die you could get a 1 a 2
a 3 a 4 a 5 or a 6 so for example I
could get a 1 with the first I and a 1
with the second die and actually that
meets our constraints but we won't go
there just yet so this is one member of
our sample space getting a 1 in the this
first die and a 1 on the second die I
want to be clear these are independent
events the second die does not know what
happened for the other die and vice
versa they're just going to each roll
independently of each other so these are
independent events they don't affect
each other and so all of these are all
the situations where I roll 1 on the
first die these are all situations where
I roll 1 on the first die and then the
second die I could get a 2 a 3 a 4 a 5
or a 6 and let me put commas here so
that's not 11 so that's one in a21 and
a31 and a41 and a 5 1 and a 6 and so
these are all situations where I roll a
2 on the first die a 2 on the first time
we're gonna fully build out our sample
space and then these are all the
situations so this is a 2 and a 1 a 2
and a 2 3 4 5 6 I could keep filling it
that way or I could say hey these are
all the scenarios where I roll a 1 on
the second die so I have a 1 over here
one over here one over here one over
here these are all the situations we
have a 2 on the second die
these are all situations where I have a
three on the second die of four on the
second die a five on the second die and
a six on the second die and then here
all situations where have a three on the
first die three three three three and
three almost done and these are
situations with a four on the first die
for so this is rolling a 4 and a 4 this
is rolling a 4 and a 5 4 and a 6 these
are five on the first I 5 almost there
one roll left
and these are rolling a 6 on the first
die 6 on the first die so each of these
each of these I guess you can view them
as cells let me draw it as an actual
grid as a chart so let me split it up to
make it a little bit neater hopefully it
makes it a little bit neater so let me
draw some lines here and let me draw
these to make it you see it's a grid so
on this chart each of these cells each
of the little boxes show a possible
outcome they show a possible outcome
they are member of our sample space they
are a member of our sample space and let
me just draw a couple of more lines and
then we're ready to think about this a
little bit more so each of these grids
this not so neatly drawn grid and each
each of these represent an outcome when
I roll two die 3 on the first type 3 on
the second die 5 on the first type 3 on
the second die for on the first I 5 on
the second die these are all the
possibilities and you see there's 36 of
them because there's six different
possibilities for the first die and six
different possibilities for the second
die 6 times 6 is 36 now how many of
these possibilities how many of these
outcomes how many of these simple events
meet the constraint the constraints for
our compound event and a compound event
is just an event that has more than one
possible outcome that satisfies it so we
want to roll doubles so how many ways
can we roll doubles well that's doubles
right there
that's doubles right there that's
doubles right there that's doubles right
there that's doubles right there and
that's doubles right there that's what
we call it a compound event
holding doubles is a compound event let
me write this this is a compound event
compound event fancy word for just
saying there's more than one outcome
that meets that that we could say this
event has happened a simple event would
be what event that's associated with
only one outcome this event is
associated with multiple outcomes so if
you want to figure out the probability
of rolling doubles the probability of an
our event here is rolling doubles
rolling doubles which is a compound
event rolling doubles it has more than
one event associated with it it's a well
how many events are how many simply has
more than one outcome associated with it
more than one simple event associated
with it this is a compound event how
many of the possible outcomes are
associated with this event so we have
one two three four five six six six
outcomes associated associated with this
event with this event and then how many
total possible outcomes are there what
we already said there's a total of 36
possible outcomes 36 possible possible
outcomes the size of the sample space is
36 so the probability of rolling doubles
is 6 there's six different ways I can
roll double out of a possible 36
different ways of actually rolling the
die so it's 6 36 and we can simplify
that because it's just a fraction 6 over
36 they're both divisible by 6 so you
can divide the numerator and the
denominator by 6 that's the same thing
as 1 over 6 1 out of 6 so another way of
thinking about it I have a 1/6 chance
when I roll to die of coming up with
doubles or 1/6 of all of the
possibilities of rolling to die 1/6 of
them result in actually getting doubles